Half three and farrier homework, worked as our happiness by MAC on the bridge.
Yes, that you tell us exactly how you employed under combined watcher which dollars the lifeless workmanship.
This dawn on me cemented alive nineteenth of July 's nineteen twenty six,
and no the first two years I was employed on a template floor baking tempers for the various members get as a bridge
and after two years I was transferred out of the workshop.
I went through marking off assembling
and riveting film through various processes of PA manifest how they Curtis Curtis what do you workshops were like her
exact to the presence of weapons went through the workshop. He has raw material came in from overseas.
From England and the a lot of this sort of semi- repair had prepared
and was marked off guillotine door policies just to settling cutting her marked off with river drills
and so the assembly line and providing. From there to intervene to have a shop and assembles further to the first page.
What was your job in the first place with marking of whether it is the process about the captivating
when making the templates polly Curtis
and I were transferred elderly chopping users templates where there are many of the same set of Mike individually
failures of templates and then they were a month off the templates.
Yes, not all, but there are quite a number the cliff these
or used successfully excessively throughout the year workshops,
but also a little over Martin from the drawings themselves
and as a quite out of the skill applied in reading the drawings and accurate marking off
and do what was the year the accuracy that was required was at absolute accuracy what service it all in all,
Rome was at special in a particular job well similar cases very special comment on how to be right,
especially jointing parts and the year when I went out of sight.
They are to be right not just near enough firm with you go along from the year.
The marking out to show we say the that the assembly.
The Baltic heartburn meticulous in the process of that exactly who alleged the minimalist sort out the various parson
they were assembled and window checked and rechecked course they had the inspectors are,
but it left a party going through checking on us. We were doing something.
There is a minimum area for the states
and factor is a design level of do remember how they hear aligned at each each member with that with the next bottle of
estimates of the use of automated by tapes have long steel tapes released tapes.
They also around one hundred feet long and weighs to vary her.
She do expanding contract with the weather and they used to be checked each week on the thing,
and sometimes it up to the waterway construes them to bring to our is a right accuracy
and her several the very strict upon tickertape is right to know you are not good enough.
There is a heard said that there was no curved members of the bridge 's is correct well you were to come in the top
arch their dislike killer to my SIG I should say
and commit only what it was like in the year in heavy shopping are you doing riveting in their year twelve senior
served the big job moderator submit these skills later claimed attack one hundred
and company so am colliding them up on the system big wooden girders and blocks to line up in these
and the quite an amount of shipping around them to position and they were bolted together.
There and checked
and rechecked before are set out on assembly about Lilly approach strands group we were actually limiting yourself well
I did do some riveting there quite a bit near the end of my time commission quits all stages of the trade of was there.
Could it was about to further work of a riveting gang yes well agenda working now is River holder up them as a river
cook is a chap who used to catch surrealists in place on the whole point Leo Rivers to her login
and health quota skilful operation and the rivet have to be a hot enough to hotseat and media cook and
or the Optus has a is correct as of the process started with the year the River copper.
He had a princess have what sizes who worked out what size of events they had to be cooking at any given time the river
generally he would emphasise a result handled a have bought their put in the other woman at the right torture raked out
to catch early as there was to, catcher at kerosene tin,
then throw to make some distance of ten fifteen hours a time that is privileged place it in the whole folder holder up
to hold a collar of a real.
He has lets them that this is a fair picture given the size of events with any bigger than anywhere else in all
and up from the high milk from the half insist size up to its in court.
I think that the given most of the jobs are to think emollient
and caught a one's head of the size river by a machine relating bacteria
or to what sort of machine was that hydronic river hydronic bidding screen.
Markedly to describe one had operated yesterday as a hydronic river Sligo because she'll which would straddle together
and the same process for the River compere cooker is the place for the whole family is to come down to clamp action
hydronic camp action squeeze rivets tightly into their founder of the tightness of the of the river came from the
contraction of the rivet on cooling the separate matter pristine with a hydraulic action squared right up till in a
state put the penny clearance and the holes are taken up by the hot metal being squeezed right up or no movement.
Whatever, and these in turn clatter on rechecked by relevant specialist: will a small hammer
and cap each visit treated as any movement, and if so, have nearly one like that they were marked and cut out
and replaced given a lot of rivets being replaced on the bridge at times it is a fault in the hydraulic system analyst
team right up to be quite another cut out that would happen to remember how the year.
The allotment is of steel work we shifted around the the workshop to remember that the size of the members GST is quite
heavy members
and iodine is twenty in charge are staged DLL joists Culbert following Alliance write-down of the various sizes media
is there ever had the cranes transfer cranes from which they come out by both the law is an transfer granular workshops
and in the light workshop, there were two bays mainly won't marking off.
Assembling and riveting can I take it back to the time where you
when you first got a job at the London can you remember how you got the job
and can your member distiller 's story of are over.
Apply for a job in getting up, I applied to the job there
and are soon after never got left Avenue reveal your plans with is a a black door Molloy company at Dawes point because
they are close to normal Playford apply to the job: company has turned apprentice, year workshops
and in the hospital of the to the starting time of him wanted to its later tender when I started there has,
so I have to do further workshops. What I would go through tender.
I was told by the manager role London is an indispensable luck that said that this is a very important job is worth
doing is worth doing well.
I always remember that and there was Mister Henry Martin is a workshop manager,
it is never much to do with after that they know that well. He was also around the workshops up-and-down E.
Coli
and workers are investors that are quite a bit to remember any any tragic incident signing you accidents such in the in
the workshop jester was one where one day of the remember her tragic accident there one day
and I just forget the gentleman 's name electrician tender Caleb Nicol Boyle and a much of that resentment over.
District years ago, gambling fifty years at ten thousand one
and nine hours several other minor to serious accidents just being hit by girders
and her steelwork falling on the tender but out on the site where I was never very much at all.
There are a few accents quite a few of their mental
and chap Hurstville Pilate one-day was killed momentous time chapter name of Kelly fell off the arch into the harbour
and survived her that was too that I remember very well put,
or others as we may not about to remember her arm many amusing incidents around the around the workshops where he
worked. Yes oh one.
Outer never forget on a stomach ownership how age of seventeen she was limits per week for our first year
and during the first years as a variation of the award and we got one penny a week rise which is all dictatorial,
however, one twenty bought two cigarettes to which is a lot for apprentice there and the course next year.
It went up about campus for the second year and surgery about one six.
However, last year we were getting about the power of three pounds one assumes a week which included two
and six is weak for passing our third year to technical exam so it died us what her second jetting exam graduate
successfully extra you do remember the working conditions are in the workshops lawyer scroll that quite I suppose at
the ties are normal though no were canteen.
No were showers were dressing rooms just Baltic code up from somewhere were of you could no morning tea afternoon teas
like part of a heart citizen Tbyte ability aged Einstein sat around workplace had a lunch
and nerve launching up facility serve but he went to attempt what Japan's timber should have seen some time
and depilatories what colour it was dim under the dust and if you do with your say I remember it,
didn't remember the dust that is apparently had the floor will the floors of dirt# the floor
and her very dusty at times and now that act watered down that down a bit and geriatric times
and especially Peter went off the harbour that it was soon as workshops was bitterly cold and less dust fly.
There is a very year in a dreadful times
but her about the condition work without incident during a lunch as carefully as about forty two minutes
or forty five minutes and no matters extended our lunch hours there and they are everybody having outside
when the whistle went through the exodus over workplace Claire worked straight away from the Crown
and can yes a lot of our lunchtime is still I work it out.
I don economic rain Frenchman when owners are trenching of frontiers are called in
and he is to run this crap in anger at lunchtime
and know it around me in Australian law where all are now higher there than over the Crown and anchor
and a bit put pending up through silly whatever,
and now he ran a company for their call the years after the day there is a very excited chap Frenchy Hamburger Hill.
I say he has Donovan on the crane happens to some mishap happened are something I'd injured
and he was very upset is upset that equipment is crowning of us find that the at least one thing I remember about her
and that this is another chap there was an SP bookmaker is to take bets on the side of thought by with a bit of paper
just leave it.
I'm reworked them head look at the cefaclor was around going to the paper and no, it was as though her Bentley, Harrow,
his name was and the heat is lost sight of a boilermaker Leanne is to take the bets and in those days as an island,
have transistor radios and get the result race results disembowelled only days
and sometimes a racist title eleven o'clock in the morning and people putting their bets on their shilling each way
or sixty feet by whatever I petitions with the new Vic bit
and to get the results just about a barbershop how North Wilson 's point and there Jimmy barber shops
and hotels of a source getting information from raises
and this barbershop tippee result somehow am to get the message through a little window through a hole in the size were
shot dead as shoving Linux trains as a whole cut in their permission to come through there with the result of the race
was at another time.
I remember another time when the train to come in a business point
and it up online at a shunt to try entitled to the message on the race and it was another source of information
and ideas of clever enough things
and were shocked they went on to company article eleven OES that we can appear lunchtime different times
and I remember one time are very well.
Her two levels with up the laptop and just before the last part of the joint and there were a few place across.
We crossed and no which we should not have done, we came back in the summary: this who went back in the form
and character dressing down and there have one chapter,
yet this chap Charlie none is dead now held for Mister Al Smart is inkling investment
and details address in Downey said long I loved that put the company. If you fallen chart is all costs.
Loss of others to develop that the latest will you would do it again.
So, because I think some dollar to go up there and no, I have a good photograph that once,
subject to a focused step of Austen hired crawl up on top of the creeper crane or halfway up
and out a photograph taken of eighteen downwards which was the interest shown around the workshop ten in our section in
the form got to hear of it
and gave me a dressing down about ten years at world as we counter these things that they were things that happen.
They honeys oppose only when the younger do it, but looking at these
or early Whitehead lecture Billy Whitehead do I ever feels and I'm work of their peers a strong man in his own right
and elderly strongman acts and here to give birth at lunchtime there particular, namely a dead cat, however,
have the ropes
and shake for the Cardinal 's car boys takes on head laydown on a board with all males protruding through it.
I am that ministers can take his shirt off and that the rock on his chest chats with a sledgehammer
and breakers brought and it is the rock breaker sieges thought and it painted sees the idea
and I only write take the weight off with your elbows on the ground
and this too heartened Lilly came at this board is to do is back and blood coming out thing went wrong.
but However, that was it,
and another VRML about a one-day visit either a close the arts of the bridge twelve day by day.
There is a report on the papers to bridges headache OCR ticketing closer tender supposedly close on the temperature of
right and no birthday about eleven midday called if someone were to the arch can closed
when the singles given the siren in the workshop.
when Kyle could do to inciting out like that
and then all the ferries in the harbour which imagine a lot in those days all Easter as a cockatiel doing in this rush
the shop and outside how, author and harbourfront facility and everybody is looking at.
Could you couldn't see that this difference:
back in his ability waited there standard in ours folders justly back listed to new@ CBOE on a set of missing archfoes
before and that you are not enabled Karl is our results are to take office.
I was a Russian but it is all genome is swiftly below the critical of over the year to get that our quota identity.
There did you get to any memento from the with Amy arch was closed yesterday gave everybody Canberra for each tender.
I mislaid my somewhere but that could be around a lot of photographs, I hand
and that few mementos which I just can't claim a hands-on got a nice e-mail moved that Mabel over plaster thrown out by
a panel of full-time, but I cannot find them.
Do you remember will be there
and union meetings at the at the workshops GS fatality union meeting regularly cutting were nearly popped up a shop
committee. They are and was sort of a militant shop committee on the ball all the time.
Although the work that many strikes in the workshop.
So a few outside on site which is understandable mean is very dangerous.
A lot of that work
and they fought for height money in danger money which disposes only proper in those days because I took a lot of risks
to be no way these eight would be done the veneer terminal shop committee have a chat DNA was Arthur Reardon to the
fact that there could speak and feels the chairman and are when there was a meeting on figuring it out.
Alert you already are already everybody fosters emitting fair and equitable to be said that
but I do remember to three strikes are
but that didn't last for a long I remember at one time they authorise traders Ltd boilermakers.
Lucas on account of the heavy nature of the work which it was heavy power alone manhandling do should have a Leo Abare
whether for any true for men or whatever and turn these bars over and if you didn't cannabis
when you'll adhere to her break around the throne and around to seriously hurt.
I remember there one day returning a row. Her role steel joist about twenty time and no court again.
Lucas total Centre know what to do that.
I have a bit of experience and looked, and when you had up on the balanced to let go conducted odds
and if you didn't and how moderate and throw you remember very well returning one girl earlier one day someone
when they turn up under the ballast salary allowed to write about your serve leavers who wants it didn't,
and a thrilling and L the likely he missed going around in throwing strap on his feet at home
and get that it was very late yesterday for the chap do remember any other instance around workshops
or age would prefer to to other conditions.
The workshops on just can't bring to mind any other incident
but those days are workers as I said before a very heavy
and I think these days I with improved technology work would be very much easier,
as in the workshops there have been just these overhead cranes and for transporting the heavy material
and these days that have a lot of chips with electric lists have a lot of these are forklift trucks running around for
an easy presentation materials from place to place with a it ever so much easier than the one aspect that I should
think that protective worker, it easier to remember going to work are you a wed to and from work
or lawyers are in those days they were three ships in the workshops are I was on the seven o'clock pool about four
weeks to forty four hour week as a peer to catch tram six o'clock in the morning
and if there was a reduction of special chair like before six o'clock in the morning Della McKay to the ferry across to
Wilson 's point and I remember well to be a late different times, they were the fog, harbour
and no then we go to technical College three nights a week
or for seven o'clock call nine then there was no tiny back to where we lived
and capital to take out not so would walk up from the Courier particular College in Alamo putting the three nights a
week there some malign o'clock in the front we did,
did you were cover part of the day off a week confirmed the get attacked or no no no no time off at all.
So no holidays those days either remember hopping apprentices, paid for a Christmas Day Boxing Day New Year's Day
and offered was no holiday little. She just worked right up Christmas Eve.
New Year's Eve whatever Z can back to work to eliminate later that a holiday is limit sick back for sick pay customer
that laughing at present I have got it, but as compensation.
I don't remember of any first aid station boxes around in the factory in their workshops
and I remember well a couple times I got a steel splinter and no,
you contributed to what the call they Hospital Saturday fund, I think they called it about six p a week
and you went to a hospital at the outpatient department are few work at night time
and I remember very well go to work on hospital there is piece of steel out of hand
and awaited their bout three to four hours and a young doctor there I think is a student here said I'll help
or arm around in teachers are down there are forces just plunged into this tripe without stasis Dale Herbert profusely
and where it only needed to have a band aid.
These days the band is a top-down at like a boxing… and a one home
and my mother said good heavens was wrong so shown that the outlook and just go Ireland bathed
and it was a twenty to work next day,
but to this day that Peter Steele still limiting hand there wary Mister at another time I had a go back airport some
little articles cut a cut about.
If it's metre stitch went along thereby that sticking plaster around what was it went back to it. Things like that.
I mean no very primitive as far as first a night.
Can you remember when you were laid off there when was its
and written in no terms of the positioning of the bridge where was the bridge
when you got letter high finished on the July nineteen thirty one and it was near completion
and I mean they were playing off hands every Friday of each week ten of the laid off
and cost return the March nineteen thirty two,
so the main structure was built for thinking of the roadways train lines and the likes
and NAB cylinder noise notice Saturday 's ten and with recourse an hour before remember very well the year four,
we came down as a picture came down the list.
Ferrier guestbook pack up and get out tonight and that is it quick, but to pay the zone teal
and outer went in my condensers are signed up that are sent to me and no that was it finished and no,
no work in the depression as a nineteen thirty one thousand upon thousands artwork vinegar around on a bicycle round
various workshops in the city suburbs of work, but it just hopeless somewhat if you do well in March,
one week before the bridge is open, I set out a bicycle or a brother and we row these bicycles up to Queensland
and was a great experience along the road agree.
I remember well the first day is of very hot day and we pedal
and arrive at why on the first night is about sixty miles on the road those days over the Hawkesbury Mountains.
We walked past wiping pushing these bikes up. We had a very big labour.
This tent blankets constant, and delete whatever
and that could teleport River no Brits there is a year ferries traffic punts were on their
and we tackled with the chap about not paying ago over a want is to pay right left however… often enough to pay to go
across.
However, we got along the road
and made up to while the costs of this track as critic under storm K shoulder left in the local park under a band
worked in passed on to Y of and we went is so rarely occurs, show grounds, all placed shelter,
and we can then is hundreds of people there cost a lot of people know they used to jump the to the goods trains
and a temp in these whatever mainly,
show grounds of initial recall some settle down there proceeded to commemorate the night,
while a billion just came along a starter talk to us and asked his questions and sort of degrees ahead
and they were detects innovative before we left as a null couple were murdered in the city and after these murderous
and their sake written us and they showed as a card each who they were at a turnout our packs
and their were carrying references for this problem well-known people in the suburb. We would lift the Saturdays.
That is okay so… that there were proceeded on signed up the coast blue various places
and try to be uploaded on the overall is a remember well home.
We arrived in Grafton and recalled on a farm along the road. There, and as an Indian and growing a lot of corner.
Nowadays it won't out of vehicles, motor vehicles and a lot of corn
and who are caring for three days with him only basis for showing that only at our food.
Initiated loyal and a lot of money but were left
and we carried on turn on eventually where I'd environment a this is in German and ladders were just wasn't as:
there which you swim and we were there for three months and yet catch fish
and the the job to a private that if you lift the cities, a jovial contract.
Question which eradication of to keep on at various please tasers on the route
and you're only allowed to stay the place three days till it later to meet Russian out of Irvine,
who as you can draw irrational twice anoint plates celibate long profit coast after Byron Bay will quit enough to draw
there we got the job there for about monthly.
It was the best wage three pounds nine shillings a week when will it step down about a month later,
when a lot of money.
We proceeded on arrived in Brisbane and we stayed at the people 's palace there for shillings
and I postdated busily drawing a very good week
and now remembers well the solar rugby league football test massive nineteen thirty two,
which was called the Battle of Brisbane remember the very well.
However, half of the prison site along tender home in West at Ipswich and Carl,
it was very cold frost on the ground there walk on the ice could close under your feet,
and we had a cup of legacy can already ship of the night.
All that were carried on and were heading for Toowoomba
and cattle Moray a lot of restrict these westerly winds we came to the bottom of the toll bar range, gender,
a very steeply up the water we pushed our bikes up their then no halfway up the place attempt to call the Eagles nest
her analogue leader Davies or sweeping at a camp.
There are recalled in their everybody major welcome and I remember well I had blisters on my feet, who was the fleet
and no chipset looked after well and is to be a doctor, it can visit them a car.
Please paper from Toowoomba, the doctor price and no particular on their part, these people, their health and welfare.
However, we left our carry on the next day and cycle down through to a number
and her down Warwick thing we cant in the Warwick Showground and at night.
Very cold in the cycle down to Cundy Wendy onto Texas along to Ashford near Inverell,
and there is tobacco growing on their salary. However, place early in quiet and high levels.
Please taken tiles about so we want to share farmer telling Lowther 's place and he went any took a sign
and we slept in.
I will shed and web was ever about two years, cleared land built tobacco sheds at a tobacco
but being experienced blue mould.
What this out,
but we got along to trap rabbits the rabbit ship kangaroos in those days of absolute level of play proportions
and whatever your trap to say of the skins or take them into Ashford
and B skin buyers a buying rabbits kangaroos Foxtel 's whatever any about the Shillingford chart a full skin
but five shillings roundabout comes items of health and their delay get that money and kept by an Peter Rabbit now
and again will experience and the end came where we had had a write off David rotate my brother
and I head rode back to Sydney on my own the product you have another go,
so I went back to Inverell again I collected in a quick chef owners. Another chap, but same result.
The mould like as LEM then took the bike again rode back to sixty and there highly grow down
and I can get outside of your our salon Armadale, is a big rock PS tourist place now, thunderbolts rock so i.e.
So I'll stay if the night so
when out of the rotten sort of excitement from the site of officials admitted out overnight
and carload of young people came out there in our drinking the start of copper offered bottles.
The brakes are yelled out for the thirty came over and apologised,
and the whole thirteen throwing the bottles are thorough to say,
saying take this thunderbolt so-and-so so came out at a garment in that sort of thing profit went so i.e.
Proceeded on them are writing down Maya attempt at a place near the Maron by range
and the close of all is Roman Catholic Church in the Portugal a and is very tired and no,
I was asleep their hammer wake up space and break in the local priest, Gardner Church were less hurried back up
and get out at two, then I'm no content on row back on the Sydney in the year great track on the bridge of again
and they used to write around the different workshops, day after day with the same people Leah and no,
I remember very well.
We went to one place and are taking on a few
and to go around my now cycle looking for worth having it find it semi- dressed up in a bunch out there who just up
your title and only had a pair of dancing pumps on the foreman came out and is looking up and down in disorder. S.
& is it all right sector of taking obesity committee work, not you are to be traded procedures around with all those
and that a valid Visa struck on the road
and yet begun a job might last week to week 's work by job around my saffron while
and no ticket work week fortnight must so on are not, however please know in this one place thirty two years.
This time more settled in their anniversaries are followed up second nineteen
and the poet another place where was this that you were pathetically is that Crompton Parkinson supplied
and thirty two years by the fall in their private twenty years, having get on there when it is hostile.
There are no October nineteen thirty seven, during the depression. It is all ages.
Things are getting a bit better than a style of October nineteen thirty seven was in Transformers formally shop there
for over twenty years and now eventually they close down that section in transformer making
and the size shorter retiring age and I've got another job
and Westinghouse at her Lord because ever about six years I was employed as Inspector speaking welding work was of
contract located in a notice to you are very deaf over whether to get the deafness will transfer the lifetime in the
trade of all the noise a lot of hammering and especially in the transport seven thirty two years
and mainly take work
and their reverberations from the tank work noise having whatever at turn causes international justice together
compensation for this ISA did can do feel that this conversation
and others you could very gruff voice to win that can prompt us to voice well,
I suppose how somebody with your following throughout.
He is a trade visit the fumes from the welding ninety think
or do think assert just general dust that could contribute to feel some dust we has marker either non-smoker.
The last time I had a smoke New Year's Eve nineteen twenty nine and I were going to work on us on the Harbour Bridge
and I